it's real simple more money more
problems more people more energy
[Music]
yes so here in Fort Lauderdale to give a
speech tomorrow morning and the package
we put together what the organizers was
to do a dinner before I'm doing one in
Denver as well we'll be doing it in DC
and Arizona later in the year right and
one other place I think about more yeah
all right got it
so and budget really just so a lot of
fun you know three four five seven nine
ten twelve depending on each market I
think this one's three or four and so
what excited for it should be fun it's a
good book you're reading yeah how are
you good let's meet you mom excited for
you
yes that's exactly what you should be
doing
touring uh yep thanks for reading thank
you thanks for reading it that's very
nice so what school manager angel thank
you thank you I live up north to hear a
little bit for about nine years I have
offices all over the country I drove
over from Naples today is that where you
live got people flying them for the
event tomorrow tomorrow all over the
country no I don't live there though got
it now I live out Phoenix are called
Phoenix in my corporate headquarters
home I say I used to live up the street
here a little bit about nine years in
person weird many Chris from Gary
Vaynerchuk table Joseph subpoena that's
a nice email pleasure
are you kidding throughout the be here
look serious guys thank you so much for
joining me yeah yeah so here's the thing
that's me so we're
for my company will do projected right
now to be a little over and I've been
struggling they're going to pass that
how about next goal come on babe let's
start there before we go anywhere else
you got agree with me that's completely
arbitrary it just seems like the next
logical exciting place to go right which
is fine it just you like the carrot of
it's good I get it
okay go ahead so for me to get there I
feel like I'm out the last few years
I've hired a couple CEOs with it right
you thought you were gonna bring in the
mature person that's gonna take you that
next place not even mature man just
thought they had built it all the
prerequisites
what were the prerequisites knowledge
level want to biggest thing I mean it's
a [ __ ] commitment and I get that
that's the biggest struggle is it's not
their company so they're not gonna have
that same or it's hard for me to find
that guy but I like to so bring up from
within guys that come through the range
you know but all the top salesmen and
managers that I have currently there's
just all miss in that well there's a
couple things one of the first things I
think I really really taught my dad like
when I think about my life about like
teaching my dad stuff which is always
weird as a you know an interesting I
just remember this very clearly I think
one of the things that especially you
know my dad and you have a lot of
similarities my dad came from dick [ __ ]
like you know he came to America he was
23 years old lived and so I mean my mom
and dad both lived in an environment
where their whole lives that grew up
where the bathroom was outside like
Soviet Russia was no joke like you know
um
you'll never find anybody that cares
about it the way you do I get that part
and you need to lose out there I have
CEOs that will fill the film ice tour we
can't so I can grow there's other
companies that have CEOs but you're the
judge and jury of your CEO oh yeah and
you need to decide and spend some time
on are you holding them to accountable
are you are you looking for something
that's not achievable and by the way you
may or may not I have no idea who these
one or two or three people have been but
I think one of the biggest things that
entrepreneurs struggle with is
calibrating number twos threes and fours
when you scale and the deltas are all
over the place it's interesting to me
what I think about like my dad my
brother how I think about what I
expected from them you know I would I
would tell you that my shortcoming is I
don't expect enough like if you look at
my world you know one of the reasons I'm
so happy and I am Who I am and the
reason that I always try to talk to
myself is why I can be very cynical and
regretful and resentful in my 70s and
80s is I actually navigate through life
having no expectations of others at all
which is an incredible formula for the
short term I'm 42 years old I've
struggled to be upset what I'm very
acutely aware of is what I'm 70 60 80
I'm gonna be like [ __ ] everybody else
because I've made deals that aren't as
good for me because I'm the AAA and you
know I'm okay I just don't have and so I
think calibrating your expectations is
important I'll give you another thing to
think a lot about one thing that's been
fascinating to me is and I appreciate
you bringing up ego
another thing I've seen a lot of is
people that have come from nothing and
built something substantial play a game
with themselves that they need
reinforcement I I do at times that they
need reinforcement for themselves
around how good they are and so one of
the things I would think a lot about one
of the things I think I've done well and
continue to try strive for is your best
case scenario is your number two doing
all she or he needs to do all the things
that you don't want to or you are now at
a point at being 40 know that you're not
as good at and I think one thing I've
watched a lot of number ones do in
family business and small businesses and
midsize businesses that I built from
scratch is hire people who are just bees
to they're a on the same skill set and
they don't realize the reason they're
frustrated is what they need is somebody
who's completely doing something else
those are themes that I think you need
to be thinking about I'm very happy to
see I'm glad we made this work yes and
Here I am Here I am with a lot of
employees you know let's hang out but
here's my thing and I just got out of a
dinner the number one thing that
everybody in this room should hope for
is that your competitors spend time
worrying about you
I mean I you know people sometimes think
it's because of ego that I don't know
anything about people that think that
I'm competing with it's not that it's
just that I'm more worried about my
audience then a woman you know what I
think people struggle with is how much
abundance there is there's nothing
anybody here can do that's taking away
from somebody else if you're good enough
you will get everything that you want
because there's so much there's so much
money there's so much attention there's
so much opportunity there's so much
exposure
there's nothing but fat you know
whatever you do whatever you do whatever
I do all 50 people that do what I do
aren't taking away from me and people
think they are they you know people
spend so much time looking at somebody
else's post they got more likes they are
selling more product they they're on TV
and just it's it's not smart so
I respect what people think about me I
respect it I do but I don't let it
dictate what I do and I don't spend a
time on it it's one weekend and I always
used to wear suit and tie yes yes look
you look the part
but this doesn't connect with who you
actually are yeah I you know it's funny
I make fun of people I don't make fun of
I push back on the culture of watches
and Lamborghinis and this and I have a
friend Andy who really loves
Lamborghinis and I had a great talk with
I'm like I believe in that if it's
really your passion great I don't
believe in getting the car to make
yourself look cool to get the girl or to
sell people your course I just believe
in the truth if you truly love watches
or you truly love wearing us my friends
who love wearing a suit every day and
they're just as right as I am for not
wearing a suit every day it just has to
be your truth yeah and if your purpose
is changing people's life you have to
connect with them
that's where your possible my okay a
machinery I'm from Venezuela fitness
mother working with a social media like
Easter on Facebook
actually in the beginning I start like a
normal person person deal about family
dogs travels and the sea but after I saw
the people interesting about the video
for were couple years for him so I was
in videos posting tips you know under
the sign the people is coming you know
in social media actually I was I think
was the first person to show in social
media the double tiny muscle definition
well not to my soreness or say too
masculine so always all the time I was a
you to the Russian Spanish and English
some audience is most in unites type
the differences of her
[Applause]
good numbers young dad yeah it comes you
live where and if here in Miami for
pearl of any size
yeah
when did when did you when did you move
here five years ago yeah but I live in
to Venezuela and go to Europe and I
years ago because I'm Mari we do we try
in Italy in Spain for work to find a war
I don't have that so everybody from
Venezuela to Italy and then Spain and
then the u.s. yes that's exactly right
back to what you and I connect on back
to optimism the Internet is the platform
and so whether you start this number one
or number one billion it's all gonna end
up in the same place and there's by the
way their strengths and weaknesses in
both there's advantages and
disadvantages I think I'm better than
the people when you say oh that person's
a piece of [ __ ]
that's dangerous but when you don't do
well on it and focus on it you focus on
the positive that's different it's a
very fine line
[Music]
one thing that amazed me that your your
kindness that you are always that a lot
of a big time it's not about you all
your team is very kind
because I'll fire them if they're not I
mean it I mean it I mean it like I'm in
control if you know if they weren't
caught you know if I was kind and they
weren't then I'd be delirious or
delusional or or a bad operator like you
know babban will tell you that it's just
unacceptable I don't even know what else
to say like not being kind it's like I
would argue vaynermedia's biggest
problems the other way people are not
giving critical feedback because they
everyone's trying to be too nice and
then we we've gone too far like I've
spent the last year because because
people were getting fired and they were
shocked because nobody was giving them
feedback because we were over-indexing
unkindness
which everything is you know there's a
great Russian said so had a shrug kind
of made it it translates into
everything's at its best when it's
balanced but I will tell you as somebody
who believes this very much I would much
rather be on the side of over kind if
that's my weakness
that's something I'm willing to live
with yeah so nice meeting you guys nice
to meet you my friends so nice to meet
you so nice to meet you such a pleasure
[Music]
or kinda get to meeting askance each
other where do you want to sit anywheres
fine bill what are we just a week we're
two weeks of our nine days out yeah it's
crazy yeah I genuinely think you guys
are sitting on something extremely big I
think the key now is it's a single chip
when hustlers and youngsters rush eyes
are good eyes when you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're doing you're actually
doing it for the sake of making it work
I think when you get deeper in the game
then people are chirping in your ear and
and I'm just like with more attention
comes more opinions nobody was giving
you opinions cuz nobody give a [ __ ]
about what you knew it put up just like
impenetrable force we've been doing this
I'm the same way I totally get it
I think it's right I think it's right
and on that is then having the equal
balance of ego and humility like the ego
of like we did this we figured out like
[ __ ] you is right and then having the
humility of like what pieces you know
now that you understand a little bit now
that you've seen it what doesn't come as
natural what isn't as interesting to do
what is a little bit like murkier than
you like it having that humility is
important and then just figuring out
like what it is huge learning process
Pressley delegating tasks like learning
to trust people
the job understate understanding that in
86 by somebody else is better than your
100 because a thousand eighty-six is
better than 4/100 people struggle with
that [ __ ] like I'm looking for 80 fixes
you know and everybody wants you know
some [ __ ] founders are stupid they
want 110 and I'm always like
[ __ ] why would somebody care
about your child more than you like just
it's audacity it's ego it's stupid and
then you know and then others are
looking for a hundred just cuz they like
perfection or they're more anal or
type-a and I respect that but that's a
flaw for scale that's great for art yeah
thanks for my angle when I look at
employees understand what I would do the
situation that's right as long as you
understand bad to me it's defining bad
habits and death blows my big thing is
like death blows like just don't get
caught on these six things and then if
number seven through 88 isn't that
exactly like me then that's cool cuz
otherwise you would be wouldn't be my
employee you'd be me yeah at the run
good man thank you yeah I wish you guys
well
morning blog from from Fort Lauderdale
super
super excited about um meeting I just
have with the rolling loud guys putting
together one of the real impressive kind
of music festivals and now I'm heading
to the event looking forward to the
keynote and now I'm gonna answer a
question cuz that's what we do in the
back seat back seat answers the BSA
question from Nick how does one keep the
macro goal and not change it while still
changing in the micro who's struggling
well that means you haven't defined your
macro goal you know I mean you don't
change the micro goals are a hell of a
lot easier and worthwhile debating and
changing the macro goal should never
ever ever ever change for me the
ambition of the process of trying to buy
the New York Jets is my macro
professional goal the ambition to be the
greatest entrepreneur in this great
entrepreneur era in our society is is my
macro goal those two things that's
that's where I'm at and honestly only
the chase of the Jets was my true first
macro goal I've added there says I'm
like wait a minute that you know I'm not
gonna make the most money but I can
provide the most value for entrepreneurs
in this 20-year era you know is a nice
addition but I didn't change the the
other macro goal I think you can only
have like a black and white and a grey
goal I think the black and white is the
chase of buying New York Jets
the ambition to buy and I think the grey
the more kind of you know I think
there's a good like kind of selfish and
selfless way to think about things right
on the macro but to answer your question
directly you just haven't divide your
macro goal like you can't change your
Mac your macro goals your macro goal I
want to be a good man I want to I want
to cure cancer I want to I want to buy a
home in Jamaica for my mother you know
like big goals that you shouldn't really
really change or at least you know if
you're lucky enough to have achieved
them or and then Lucky's the wrong word
if you've been able to achieve them end
or if you underestimated how much you
had in you and your original macro goal
ended up being smaller I think adding to
it I would argue that's me right I would
argue that my ambition to cheat for the
chase of buying jets was obvious and
it's been in place forever I didn't
think about you know trying to make the
biggest impact as an entrepreneur and to
entrepreneurs in this era I've added
that I think that's even locked
not loftier
but it's a great to the black and white
nonetheless I think you need to try to
stretch yourself and and really
understand your macro to me the chase is
my macro and I put that into the bucket
of hey I'm frustrated I haven't want any
Super Bowls let me take care of it
myself no I can I can just you can send
me that way
okay and he's right there
[Applause]
great yeah it sound like it I heard like
the roar as you were coming those awful
crowd I turn them around I'm good I've
never heard you speak I'd love to come
sometime thank you yeah we're after this
I'm in Philly tomorrow and then I've
Denver I've several with these guys are
you doing the one yeah so maybe well
maybe we can spend a little time you got
to get me a book okay
searches sure let me uh can you find one
Babbitt is so excited I'm still your pen
real quick
Thanks I was in the greenroom thank you
so much oh thank god I'm doing so see
Kornberg please is the rice he's a beast
Robert take care say I'll give you a
very good piece of ice and this is
actually me giving myself some advice
the number one mapping them one of them
easily three biggest mistakes are making
is not repeating my most viral content
over and over and over again something
I'm starting to realize with my content
is like wait a minute I'm like Bon Jovi
I when I need to play that's the
greatest hits like it's already proven
that it's worked back to more more MORE
I see a hundred million views or two
million views or five hundred thousand
shares and I'm like [ __ ] I nailed it but
I don't what I'm what I'm starting to
nurse says I've wait a minute [ __ ]
Facebook's like it's everybody seven
billion [ __ ] people four billion
whatever like it's like I need to like
keep playing so I would tell you if you
leave with anything even tactical today
whatever was your best piece of content
literally repost it tomorrow just post
again watch what happens fascinating
something I'm starting to think a lot
more about
thanks for coming you're welcome yeah
you're welcome bro she said thank you so
much bye-bye
Eliott
thanks for coming you're welcome brother
one thing that connects all of us
whether you're an entrepreneur whether
you work somewhere whether you're
[ __ ] thrilled
whether you're devastated the one thing
that connects all of us is that for us
to take the step in what we're trying to
achieve whether its financial whether
its legacy whatever it may be the one
thing that connects us is we have to
trade on attention the things that I
desperately want everybody to leave this
talk with is understanding that
attention is just like real estate and
that attention is the gateway drug to
everything you want period before you
can tell me how great you are how
awesome what you're selling is you need
my attention or you can tell me anything
you need my attention what everybody in
this room needs to wrap their head
around is that this device owns the
attention of our society you may be
upset about it you might be sad that
when you go out people aren't talking to
each other you can do whatever the [ __ ]
you want it doesn't change the fact that
this has the attention and if you were
sitting in this room today and you have
not figured out how to put written words
audio or video into the platforms that
sit on top of this you were
fundamentally irrelevant now what you're
doing with your allocation of content
and ad spend on Facebook and Instagram
is the same thing that happens in real
estate when somebody knows they need to
buy or debated to buy something in a hot
up-and-coming area they don't their
friends did it went to up it happened
then they get sad they get another
chance to invest for 150 thousand more
but because they [ __ ] up and passed
that 150 thousand last they say no again
six months later it keeps blowing up now
it's up three hundred thousand now
you're like [ __ ] again because you
passed twice
this is the story of uber for me I
passed on Hoover's angel round twice
twice how many people read or have crush
it my first book if you go back and look
at it I acknowledge in the
acknowledgments I thanked my family and
one random person Travis the co-founder
of uber that's it I passed on one of my
best business friend's startup twice at
a four million dollar valuation and he
was one of my best buds and it went on
to become Ober I was writing twenty five
and fifty thousand dollar checks back
then if I wrote one of my normal checks
back then into that investment would
have paid me four hundred million
dollars I'm not sad
I'm being dead serious I don't give a
[ __ ] about the money I give a [ __ ] about
the freedom of playing the game
understand if you're a true red
entrepreneur in this audience you're not
in it for the money you're in it for the
game I actually love that I passed on
over twice I'm being serious
the quickest tell for me in five minutes
when I hang with somebody if they're
true bread or if they're not is are they
in it for the game or do they want to
buy a watch
[Applause]
I gotta go sorry
[Applause]
so my question involves and do my own
thing
yes okay once realizes that the job is
okay I got great news for you you'll
never know the alternative of the one
you picked you can't you can't really do
both you can you can flirt with both
right but you can't put your ass on two
toilets you know and so like like you
know you can do things but you're only
if you have two businesses you have no
businesses it's like having two
quarterbacks so I I would tell you an
incredibly beat and an unbelievable
liberating feeling that is so many of
you are struggling with so many people
here don't make decisions because
they're worried about the what-if of the
other decision this is how life actually
works you'll never know you will never
know if you bounce now and go on with
your life
solo or if you stay another three years
you're just not going to know so why
dwell on it just pick one and [ __ ]
dumb
welcome brother try to go on but you're
looking
thank you don't worry don't come on
let's go fast please before it gets
crazy
the Hoss thanks buddy I don't make money
here once it for all the people starting
their social media marketing agencies
work
[Music]
[Music]